your character the droid is seven foot
one yes so you had to be unstitched is
that correct yes yes special stilts and
then later on they were gonna add your
your robot body right in in post but in
the meantime on set you were on stilts
Diego Luna who's with you in so many of
your scene say ago he was just here the
other day and he said it was really hard
acting with Alan because I had to do
scenes with him yes and he was he said
your groin was right there yeah he said
he's had my balls yeah I mean sports
we're right here in my face that's a
great Diego Luna but yes thank you very
much
[Laughter]
[Applause]
diego luna yes oh you that hasn't been
cleaned in years
okay i'm sorry my mother's gonna be a
you probably cleaned it with your feet
so so i would think you're on this set
and you're on this big movie but you've
got to be on these stilts the whole time
that's got to get old at a certain point
or awkward well going to the bathroom
that was tough because yeah you can see
over the stalls as you walk in so you
just sort of stride in and it's like hey
Andy what's going on yeah you play
Tetris and then the urinal again even
you know right the urinal you're just
yeah and everyone's there Wow
[Applause]
judging from your space work you're a
fireman congratulations
you